à voisins le bretonneux trois candidats
s'opposent pour devenir le maire de
cette commune de 11 1426 habitants la
maire sortante alexandra rosetti
habitante de voisins-le-bretonneux
depuis 1998 ancien professeur d'anglais
se représente
parmi ces projets la construction de
l'écoquartier de la remise ou encore une
salle des fêtes
c'est celui d'avoir une salle des fêtes
un lieu dédié où les gens puissent faire
célébrer leur mariage leur anniversaire
puisque aujourd'hui voisins beaucoup de
salles de quartier mais tout est
enclavée dans des résidences où il ya
des habitations autour donc on ne peut
pas les loups et parce que voilà ça fait
du bruit par la nuit donc on en est à
prêter soit une école nos associations
soit notre petit réfectoire de 50 places
pour les particuliers avec vos voisins
avancé menée par béatrice pire à une
première campagne pour la tête de lice
salarié dans l'industrie
béatrice pira et habitant au quartier du
lac depuis huit ans elle souhaite
notamment développer les mobilités
douces et créer une assemblée vie
chinoise voisins-le-bretonneux va avoir
dans les prochaines années des défis
stratégiques importants comme l'arrivée
de la ligne 18 du grand paris et nous
pensons qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir
quelque chose en plus dans notre ville
pour réfléchir sur ses décisions
stratégiques très impactante et nous
avons imaginé ce concept d'assemblée
vestine oise enfin olivier afonso tête
de liste unie pour voisin habitant de la
commune depuis dix ans ce conseiller
municipal depuis 2015 est responsable de
contrôle interne et qualité dans un
groupe de télécommunications le candidat
souhaite notamment créer un pôle santé
et social aux tilleuls
je voudrais regrouper donc les médecins
le laboratoire
dans cette nouvelle structure moderne je
souhaiterais pouvoir mettre aussi le
ccas qui a besoin aussi de structures
d'accueil
peut-être avec un peu plus de
confidentialité pour les usagers